Do you have complex advertising
needs like automated account
management and reporting
but don't want the overhead
of manual maintenance?
I'm Xerxes, a developer
advocate at Google.
And I want you to understand
how the AdWords API may
help you to increase
your operating
efficiency and your return
on advertising investment.
This video series is designed to
help you get going with the API
starting from the
very beginning.
So, let's get down to it.
With the AdWords
API, you can build
software that manages accounts
from the customer level
down to the keyword level.
The API can do almost everything
that the average web site
does, but programmatically.
Some types of companies that
have benefited from the AdWords
API are advertising agencies,
SEM companies, and big brands
managing multiple AdWords
accounts with needs
beyond what is possible within
the AdWords web interface.
There's an entire suite
of applications and tools
around AdWords.
So how do you know if the
API is the right route
for your organization to take?
This matrix summarizes
the available approaches.
Whether you have dedicated
engineering resources, or none
at all, we have the
right tool for you.
Click the link below
to have a closer look
and decide which approach
is best for your business.
In short, the
AdWords API is used
by companies that are looking to
build custom account management
and reporting
automation beyond what
is offered by the AdWords
web interface, AdWords words
editor, and AdWords scripts.
The API allows ad words
to be deeply integrated
with your own systems,
thereby removing
the need for human intervention,
increasing your efficiency,
and automating AdWords logic
based on your business needs.
A few common use cases are
custom reporting, ad management
based on inventory,
bid management
based on business data,
and other synchronizations
with your internal systems.
So let's take each
use case in detail.
The AdWords API allows you
to programmatically retrieve
report data and store it
in your own databases.
You could then create
custom dashboards
for monitoring the performance
of accounts, including
fine-grained details such
as per keyword statistics.
Powerful segmentation
and filtering options
allow you to slice and dice
data without extra client side
logic.
With the AdWords
API, your software
can pause and add when
stock is depleted,
then unpause when stock
becomes available.
So visitors to your site will
never be taken to a page only
to find that an advertised
item is of stock.
No more wondering if your
ad budget is well spent.
And you'll see
conversion rates climb.
The AdWords API allows you to
incorporate your own business
data into bid decisions.
For example, you
could adjust bids
based on your inventory,
cost changes, or sales.
Some clients use the API
to integrate information
from AdWords with their
internal systems such as billing
or conversion tracking.
For instance, they may
want offline access
to data such as campaign and ad
group listings, or performance
statistics, such as
impressions, clicks, cost, click
through rate, et cetera.
They may also want to
programmatically create
AdWords accounts
for their clients
based on data from a CRM system.
So the API can do a
lot of powerful stuff.
But it should be noted
that using the API
is a serious commitment.
Several versions are released
in [? sunset ?] each year.
So before deciding to
develop with the API,
ensure that you have the
engineering resources
and that you have a
business need that
is not met by the AdWords
website or AdWords scripts.
If you think that
the API is the best
route for your organization,
keep watching the videos
in this series to build
your very first AdWords API
application.
If you'd like to brush
up on AdWords words
basics before continuing,
here's a useful resource.
Thanks for watching.
I hope to see you
in future episodes.
And don't forget to subscribe
to the Google Developers YouTube
channel.
[MUSIC PLAYING]